I was born in this checkout line I
raised my kids in this checkout line I
think I'll die and just checkout line hi
guys I'm Mariah I were good BuzzFeed and
this Thanksgiving I'm going home to
Minnesota and I'll be spending Black
Friday at the biggest mall in America
now this is not a normal mall the Mall
of America has five hundred and twenty
stores over four floors it has an
amusement park a flight simulator a mini
golf course and aquarium and one of the
world's largest muir mazes it's so big
it has its own counterterrorism unit
growing up I've spent some time in the
mall but I've never been there on Black
Friday so this year I've enlisted some
friends to help me find the biggest
deals in the entire mall I'll see you
guys on Black Friday at 5:00 in the
morning
okay I'm finally here I'm at the Mall of
America and I'm feeling pretty good
I'm ready to shop I'm ready to find some
deals and I'm ready to go find my
friends Black Friday is the exact kind
of trap I love to fall into where I'm
tricked into buying things that I can't
afford because they're cheaper than
usual inside you have to be prepared you
have to have a plan and you have to have
a plan B are you prepared to fight
someone to get a better deal okay now
we're gonna head into this monstrosity
but first we need to get pumped so I'm
making all my friends shotgun Red Bulls
the mall is essentially like a giant
circle that you just kind of have to
keep walking around and around and
around I swear to God everyone and their
cousin is in this Best Buy right now so
many people just saw someone break a
hundred dollar bill at the cash register
it's madness I'm walking through the
amusement park so I'm in the heart of
the mall
feeling a little stressed I haven't
found anything in this store that I like
it all I'm feeling pretty overwhelmed
right now like I've been walking for
days flustered I don't get flustered on
Black Friday
I'm looking for the percent offs I think
those are generally better than the
dollar amounts off I'm about to name my
firstborn child Nordstrom Rack right now
I've never worn a scarf but I might
start these shoes were $44 then they
took 75% off for clearance and now
they're taking 30% off for Black Friday
I don't know I think you need to leave
there's so much going on it just I I
couldn't handle it
I would never come here again in my
whole life there's a line to get out of
the parking lot and I've been here 30
minutes Black Friday when all America
you win I surrender I feel like I'm in
LA but without any of the stuff that's
cool without LA and without the ocean